after 12 years of war the United Nations
estimates there are about a hundred
thousand people missing in Syria
detained or abducted their relatives
don't know if they're alive or dead now
the United Nations is preparing to set
up a new body to investigate the corner
of stone is the establishment by the
general assembly of a new international
institution to clarify the fate and
whereabouts of the missing and to
provide support to victims and their
families
I urge all member states to act and I
call on the government of Syria and all
all parties to the conflict to cooperate
it is essential to help syrians heal and
remove an obstacle to securing
sustainable peace
Mustafa welcomes the idea of the new
institution she hopes it could bring her
family news about her father Ali who was
abducted by armed men in 2013. I spent
the past nine years and eight months of
my life talking about the moment I lost
my dad
um and and and it's still very very
difficult I mean it changed it changed
our lives forever it changed it it it it
it shattered us you know I I'm I live
alone in Germany I have my mom and my
sister in Canada I have another sister
in the U.S we were a family and then
that moment when my father was firstly
disappeared by them by the Assad regime
in 2013
that's family ended forever so I I spent
I spent and I still spent the the every
day of my life
um trying to find an answer for one
single question is my dad alive
the fact that the Syrian government seat
in the general assembly meeting was
empty is pretty telling
the UN already has a commission of
inquiry on Syria an international
impartial independent mechanism as well
as the teams led by the UN special Envoy
and the un's High Commissioner for human
rights and yet on the issue of the
missing the government of Syria has not
cooperated with any of them
many diplomats fear the Assad regime
will also ignore the new body which the
U.N hopes to have up and running in a
matter of months James Bays Al Jazeera
of the United Nations